quels sont les meilleurs auteurs pour
découvrir la littérature autochtones
d'ici alors jérémy une des meilleures
manières de pouvoir découvrir les
auteurs d'ici c'est de se demander déjà
c'est quoi ici alors ici on parle du
québec en particulier c'est certain
qu'on va voir beaucoup de difficultés à
trouver énormément d'auteur parce qu'on
a une singularité en tant que peuple
autochtone c'est qu'on a eu comme
colonisateurs des gens de langue
française donc on est un îlot québec
si on ouvre ici par rapport au
territoire de l'île de la grande tortue
là il ya énormément énormément d'autant
qu'ils existent déjà qui sont publiés en
anglais et que présentement par la
chance de la demande croissante de
littérature sont traduits en français
alors par exemple un des livres que moi
je lis présentement et pas en france
justement est en anglais mais c'est un
auteur d'ici amont pour dire c'est chuck
wesh elizabeth bennet oui c'est une des
premières militante in où elle fait
tellement pour nous elle était une des
prisons première à contester les vols à
basse altitude de l'otan et son
historique en tant que famille nous qui
occupe encore aujourd'hui le territoire
est extraordinaire d'ailleurs elle est
présentement offert une tournée au
canada avec son livre mais pourquoi on
l'a pas encore vu au québec c'est que ce
livre est disponible uniquement en
anglais
et pourtant c'est un enfant d'ici un
autre document que j'aime beaucoup c'est
un document peu plus vieux et c'est un
mythe à tort et parlons nous alors c'est
d'être est des textes qui ont été
produits rassemblés par laure morali des
textes autochtones et non autochtones et
c'est une discussion d'alphonse et des
lettres ouvertes qui viennent de
plusieurs auteurs de plusieurs
communautés donc ça ce sont des textes
qui viennent d'auteur autochtone mais
qui doivent être travaillés grâce à
l'expérience d'autres non autochtone
donc il faut qu'il y ait une ouverture
je pense des maisons publication à aller
chercher des publications tonnes est
aussi acceptée le style et l'écriture
des premières nations qui ne sera pas
nécessairement celles des européens ou
des canadiens québécois francophones et
un autre texte par exemple un qui est
extrêmement justes et ancien je le
connais depuis que je suis très jeune
c'est 2-1 à donner car pêche etc
je suis une maudite sauvage s cet
extrait je pense que je le vois depuis
que je suis jeune mais commence
présentement à ressurgir un peu partout
il a été reconduit de lino aux français
et le présentement j'ai un volume show
man qui est presque uniquement en innu
au début et qu'on va mettre la langue et
nous de l'avant donc existe par exemple
avec tshakapesh le centre culture du
capech beaucoup de textes inouk n'ont
jamais été traduits en français encore
donc la question piège un peu c'est
comment connaître des auteurs d'ici mais
c'est de pouvoir s'ouvrir justement la
différence à la langue aussi qui est
distincte et d'explorer des lieux qui
vont être beaucoup plus ouvert à la
littérature autochtone et là je pense au
salon du livre autochtone qui a lieu à
wendake et d'ailleurs il ya la maison
d'édition qui est aussi une librairie un
et novak qui fournit beaucoup d'auteurs
d'ici mai dopé par tous il met des
autochtones
donc ça c'est une manière d'explorer
justement le grand la grande variété
littéraire qui existe dans les
communautés autochtones et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que de plus en plus de
gens s'ouvrent justement à la
littérature des premières nations
on le voit beaucoup grâce à joséphine
bacon peint avec natasha khan ap
fontaine qu' il y aura un intérêt
grandissant pour les auteurs autochtone
et on en voit de plus en plus au salon
du livre de montréal par exemple alors
en s'ouvrant à quelqu'un on lui donne la
chance de s'exprimer on lui donne la
chance de se faire publier
et là on peut atteindre à un niveau de 1
nombre je te dirai d'auteur autochtone à
ces grands poser qu'on peut faire une
sélection qui est à nouveau mais là
présentement c'est encore un défi qu'on
doit se donner en tant que société de
s'ouvrir à l'autre
j'espère y avoir répondu
vous allez partager cette chronique et
nous envoyer des questions à paroles
autochtone je souhaite une belle semaine